this is my 2002 Chrysler Sebring limited
convertible this is better it's the
Ferrari FF top speed 208 miles per hour
top speed on the Chrysler is I've
experienced it some around 70 yay
Chrysler let's light this candle
this cart occupies sort of a unique spot
in the Ferrari lineup it's more of a
cruiser two EPs
basically stand for four seats and
four-wheel-drive most Ferraris don't
have rear seats which is actually
designed to be sat in I put my kids back
there they of course totally loved it
quite taken with the TVs these days it's
not that unusual to have a lot of
controls on the steering wheel right if
it's a lot of controls on the steering
wheel but they all have to do with the
actual car and its performance this is
called the menechino you're able to
adjust search parameters of the edge of
the transmission the suspension in New
York City I have found it if you're
driving say a Mercedes or a BMW people
think you're kind of a jerk a Ferrari on
the other hand it's almost like you're a
parade float you have to make sure that
you don't scratch up the car on your way
to getting your big back yeah can I get
six cheeseburgers
now even Ferraris have all of these
little amenities and creature comforts
that used to only be found in city bands
without I got cheese on the Ferrari I've
driven in reticle sports cars there's
something about this car though where
it's sort of the whole package and that
makes it maybe perfect